we are looking across the strip and
still got the holiday lights on a couple
of the buildings
officially hanging at 39 degrees but we
wanted to check in on your neighborhoods
and we definitely have some chilly
readings
maybe not as chilly because we have a
blanket of cloud cover
and we can't even rule out the
possibility of a passing sprinkle
no measurable rain and i think most of
us are going to see absolutely nothing
37 for centennial hills you know it's
cloudy when kyle cannon is at 32
at five o'clock in the morning outside
of town also further
evidence that the blanket of cloud cover
is covering most of the state because
yesterday at this time
ely was uh verging on below zero
readings now at 26 caliente you're 24
and there's a much better likelihood of
passing snow flurries up over northern
nevada over the hump and prop you're
below freezing at 31 death valley at 44.
we're going for 55 for the high on the
last day of 2020 that'll put us one
degree below normal
our current temperature is the low so
far this morning so
a combination of breezes and wind maybe
not as strong as we'd originally been
forecasting but man if you're going to
be out after midnight tonight you've
definitely got to bundle up
so for your family and friends it is a
snowy new year in parts of texas
otherwise heavy rain with the
possibility of tornadoes over dallas
and what we thought were going to be
some snow showers from new york city on
our live shots from times square where
no one will be allowed tonight
it is just rain let's check out your
seven-day forecast getting you into the
first day of 2021 with a 56 but again
it's going to be around 40 at midnight
tonight to welcome in the new year and
breezes upwards of 20 miles an hour
a really nice first weekend with highs
in the mid 50s chilly lows in the mid
30s
climbing up close to 60 for tuesday
before some possible stormy changes
later next week that we'll keep an eye
on for you